aujourd'hui notre quotidien ressemble à
un confinement ça veut dire que ça fait
quatre ans qu'on ait continué on
espérait une aide de la france on
espérait être rapatriées dès que dès que
le calme se ferait
malheureusement aujourd'hui on a reçu la
nouvelle du ministère des affaires
étrangères qui clairement nous annonçait
un peu son abandon qui nous demandait de
partir par nous mêmes on a essayé de
contacter l'ambassade
dans la foulée histoire d'avoir des
informations de savoir
à quoi il fallait s'attendre et quelles
possibilités s'offraient à nous
l'ambassade a été enfin la cellule de
crise a été clair hier qu'aucune
possibilité s'offre à nous maintenant il
faut nous de bruit pour nous par nous
mêmes on est partis allant à la gare 15
heures
la gare c'est vraiment une scène qu'il
faut vivre pour le croire c'est à dire
qu'on se retrouve presque dans ce film
delà de la seconde guerre mondiale qu'on
n'aurait jamais vécu
les femmes et les enfants d'abord les
étrangers sont pas que pour être en
est pas remis